YEAH GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE PUBLIC WELCOME
THE SILICON VALLEY A PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT BOARD
AGAIN I'LL TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO
GO THROUGH A FEW OPTIONS AND
PROTOCOLS FOR THIS HEARING TODAY
WELL STATE CAPITALS OVER THE
PUBLIC AND WEARING A MASK IN THE
LONG REQUIRED WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THAT MATTHEW WARNED IN
ALL COMMON AREAS ENSURE SPACES
IN THE CAPITAL INCLUDING THIS
HEARING ROOM WE ALSO STILL
ENCOURAGE INDIVIDUALS TO
CONTINUE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. FOR THIS HEARING THE
PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE IN PERSON
OR ON THE PHONE THIS WILL BE OUR
LAST HEARING ON THE PHONE
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN SO YOU CAN
APPEAR IN PERSON AT THE CAPITOL
. HOW THE MISSILE DAHLE IT'S
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. IN ROOM FOR
THE STATE CAPITOL. WERE MEETING
IF ANYONE THIS ROOM WAS
TESTIFYING A BILL. UNLESS THEY
COME FORWARD AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY BUT
PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. AFTER DONE SPEAKING
YOU CONNECTS THIS ROOM A RETURN
YOUR SEATS. IF YOU LEAVE THE
ROOM PLEASE LIMIT ELEVATOR USED
TO WHAT IS DESCRIBED ON THE SIZE
IN THE ELEVATORS. THAT'S ALL
THERE'S NO CAP ON ELEVATOR SPACE
NOW. WELL TO TAKE THAT OUT.
FURNACES COIL PHONE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE THAT MRS CAN USE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE COLOR OF
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. THE FINEST PHONE NUMBER ON
THE BOTTOM OF YOUR TV SCREEN OR
OTHER VIEWING DEVICE. FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL BEGINS
PRESENTING THE BILL. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. DEPENDING
ON THE SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE WHEN THEY ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE SUCH AS MEETING YOUR TV.
LIVE STREAMING BROADCAST OTHER
SMART DEVICES. BARKING DOGS
MEOWING KIDS CATS. THE CHIRPING
BIRDS BAD KIDS OR OTHER NOISES
TO REDUCE INTERRUPTION AND SELL
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING SUBSTANTIVE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. REMAIN
ALIVE LINE- NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL. YOU'RE CALLED ON
. BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT A HOT SO
THE SPEECH. YOU DON'T WANT TO
HEAR NON BUILDING CONVERSE. ARE
NO BUT IT ELSE MIGHT HAVE ON IN
YOUR PERSONAL. EVERYONE IS ALSO
WHERE THIS COMMITTEE ACCEPTS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE ENCOURAGES
THOSE WHO HAVE ANY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES TO USE THIS OPTION
. WE'RE LIVING TESTIMONY THE
PARTY WINS. FOR EACH BILL TO TWO
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT AND TO IN
OPPOSITION. EACH OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHAT TWO MINUTES
MAXIMUM TO SPEAK. WITH OUR
LISTEN TO PART ME WITNESSES
REGARDLESS OF POSITION. THE
MAXIMUM TWO MINUTES STILL
APPLIES. AFTER PROMISES ARE DONE
EVERYONE ELSE SHOULD BE
PERMITTED TO SAY THEIR NAME
ORGNIZATION IF ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. IF THE STATE ESTATE
THE EXCUSE ME. IS THERE ANYTHING
I'M BILLS THREE WORDS ALL
INTERRUPT YOU AND ASK THE PHONE
OPERATOR TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BEAKER. THE SIMPSONS PRESS THE
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE FLOOR PROCEEDINGS THE
LAST FEW YEARS. SO EVERYONE IS
CRYSTAL CLEAR. CONDUCT THAT'S
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR PIZZA OR
CONDUCT. THIS HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. TO ADDRESS JUST TO
ADDRESS NEEDS DROP OF CONDUCT. I
WOULD RECKON THE STOP ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT THE CONTINUED.
THEY WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE
PROCESS BEING THIS HEARING. AS
APPLIES TO IN PERSON AND FULL
PARTICIPATION AND IF NECESSARY.
WHICH EMPLOYEE RECESSES HEARING.
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE. THIS
HEARING WILL NOT END ON THE
AGENDA AND WHAT CONSENT. WORK
OUR WAY THROUGH THE GENTLEMAN
FILE ORDER- I SEE DOCTOR REBELS.
REMOVED HIS BILL- ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. AB TWO SIX. DR REBEL- BUT
SPOTS SO WE'RE GONNA DO- FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY
FIFTEEN CLUES ON THE CONSENT
FIVE THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN FONG HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. IN THE
ABSENCE OF ASSEMBLY COOLEY
ASSEMBLY MICHAEL TODAY ASSEMBLY
RODRIGUEZ WILL SUCH TO FOREIGN
DURING THIS HEARING. AND HE'LL
BE HERE SHORTLY HOPEFULLY FLOWS
YOU'RE WONDERING THERE'S NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR THE VACANCY FOR
THE HEARING. BEFORE YOU BEGIN.
JUST STE OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO STARS A SUBCOMMITTEE. DR
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. THANKS ON EASY
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN TODAY. WITH
REQUIRES CONDITIONS REQUIRE. YOU
CAN OVER A NUMBER OF. THANK REAL
FACILITIES TO BE FILLED BY CIVIL
SERVANTS SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
VACANCY RATES FOR STAFF
PSYCHIATRIST AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTION FACILITIES AND
STATE HOSPITALS HAS BEEN ABOVE
FORTY PERCENT. WELL FEWER
SUPERVISORY POSITIONS ARE
AVAILABLE THERE ARE SIMILAR
VACANCY ISSUES THIS IS DESPITE
HAVING FULL TIME CIVIL SERVANTS
AT THESE HOSPITALS APPLYING FOR
SUCH SUPERVISORY DUTIES. INSTEAD
OF HIRING WITHIN SOME FACILITIES
HAVE TURNED EXTERNALLY TO
CONTRACT OUT TO FILL THESE
POSITIONS TEMPORARILY. FOR THE
FACILITY PSYCHIATRIST THEIR
PATIENTS AND THE STATE
CONTRACTING OUT SUPERVISORY
POSITIONS CAN CAUSE
INSTITUTIONAL TURMOIL INTERRUPT
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICE AND
INCREASED COST TO THE STATE. AS
AN EXAMPLE OF THOSE COST
INCREASES YOU APD IS FOUND THAT
FOR STAFF PSYCHIATRIST ALONE
CONTRACTORS ARE PAID ROUGHLY
TWICE AS MUCH AS THEIR CIVIL
SERVANT COUNTERPARTS. AS YOU
WILL HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES
CIVIL SERVANTS ARE READY AND
WILLING TO FILL VACANCIES. THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FILLED BY. AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY WILL ENSURE
CONTINUED GROWTHOF
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE STAFF
COHESION AND CONTINUITY
INPATIENT SERVICES IN OUR STATE
HOSPITALS AND CD R. FACILITIES I
AM JOINED TODAY BY DOUG CHIP
PETA IN PERSON AND SPENCER
DAVIDSON ON THE PHONES FROM THE
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS. THANK YOU DR RANIA-
DECK CHIPATA- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS ALSO THE- CHAIR OF THE
ASKED ME CALIFORNIA STEERING
COMMITTEE- I WANTED TO I THINK
OBVIOUSLY DR RAMBLE FOR
INTRODUCING THIS- NEEDED A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION- IT IN A RELATED-
PIECE OF LEGISLATION MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
ASSEMBLY BILL. SIX FIFTY SEVEN-
WHAT THE OBJECTIVE IS TO REIN
IN- CONTRACTING OUT OF THIS IS A
VERY- SIMPLE BILL EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT THERE'S A LONG STANDING
PROBLEM OF CONTRACTING OUT WITH
RESPECT TO CIVIL SRVICE JOBS.
WITH THE- I THINK DONE A
THOROUGH JOB OF EDUCATING- AND
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF- MR
BOLTON'S VERY COMPETENT IN THIS
AREA- SO THERE'S NO NEED TO
REHASH THAT THIS IS A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD PROBLEM. WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT- VACANCY RATE- WOULD
FOR PSYCHIATRY AND DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AND ALSO DEPARTMENTS
THEY HOSPITAL'S APPROACHING
5560% BUT REALLY THE CORE OF
THIS BILL. IS THAT. A CONTRACTOR
CANNOT FILL A SUPERVISORY
POSITION BUT IN THIS CASE VERY
SPECIFICALLY. WHAT YOU HAVE OR
CONTRACTORS THAT HAVE BEEN
FILLING THE ROLE OF MEDICAL
DIRECTOR WHO OVERSEES STATE
PSYCHIATRISTS AT STATE. OF
HOSPITALS AROUND OF THE STATE WE
HAVE FIVE OF THEM ONE IS
COALINGA IN IN- DR ROMULUS
DISTRICT WILL SERVE METROPOLITAN
STATE HOSPITAL. PENN STATE
HOSPITAL IN THE LA AREA WE HAVE-
NAPA STATE HOSPITAL IN SENATOR
DODDS- AREA AND THEN OBVIOUSLY A
TUSKER THEY'LL STATE HOSPITAL- I
BELIEVE OUR SECOND WITNESS WILL
SPEAK TO THAT- SO WE HAD. AS AN
EXAM SUB FORCE OR FIVE CIVIL
SERVANTS PSYCHIATRIST DULY
QUALIFIED TO APPLY FOR THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR THERE AND IT'S
A POSITION OF PRESTIGE. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY INSTILL-
YOU KNOW COULD YOU COULD YOU CAN
SURELY ALITY BUT ALSO- IT'S A
CLINICAL AMONG SOCIETY
PSYCHIATRIST YOUR- YEAH- IT'S A-
A BADGE OF HONOR IF YOU ON THE
FIELD OF MEDICINE. TO BE A
MEDICAL DIRECTOR MEDICAL
DIRECTORS ARE NOW BEING FILLED
BY CONTRACTORS AT THE TUSKER
THEY'LL STATE HOSPITAL WE HAD
FOUR FIVE CIVIL SERVICE A
PSYCHIATRIST. A PLAN FOR THIS
JOB THEY'RE ALL TURNED AWAY AND
THEY PLAY A PART OF THE APPROVED
A MEDICAL DIRECTOR WHO'S A
CONTRACTOR. FOR IN ACTING
CAPACITY FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS. AFTER HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
THEY RE UP HIM FOR ANOTHER
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS- IN DOING
OUR RESEARCH WE FIND THAT THIS
IS A PROBLEM THAT IS RAMPING UP
OTHER STATE HOSPITALS AND ALSO
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. SO THIS BILL BY DR
ROBBIE THAT WILL ALLEVIATE THAT
PROBLEM MAKE SURE THAT- WHEN
SOMEONE ASCENDS TO THE POSITION
OF MEDICAL DIRECTOR WHICH IS A
SUPERVISORY POSITION- THEY WOULD
PUT IN THEIR TIME. AS A CIVIL
SERVANT AND HAVE PATIENT CARE AT
THE FOREFRONT- I THINK DOCTOR
OPULENT AND THAT WE URGE YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE STUDY
LEGISLATION. AND NOW IT WILL I
THINK WE'LL HAVE A SECOND
WITNESS THANK YOU. OPERATE I
THINK THANK YOU EVERYONE. IN THE
WELL HI I THINK EVERYONE THE DAY
WITH RAPID FOR THE UNION OF A
PHYSICIANS AND THEN. DURING THE
CALL OF MY DUTIES AS A THANK
POSITION MEMBERS TO MY- THAT A
CONTRACTOR BY PIRATES SAID TAP
HERE THE POP. BUT PLATE INTO A
TIE CAL OF MEDICAL. THEY HAVE
MANY CONCERNS NAMELY THE FACT A
NON CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES WILL
HAVE SUPER CAP PASSED THE OVER
CIVIL. A THERE WERE FOR HI THEN
PHYSICIAN THAT WOULD BEEN AND IN
THAT POSITION. WHILE THE STATE
THIRDS A PERMANENT MEDICAL. IN
FACT PRIOR TO PLACING THE
CONTRACTOR IN THAT POSITION ATOP
HERE AT THE HOSPITAL DID PLACE
THE HOLD SERVICE VOLUNTEER THAN
THE POSITION IN AN ACTING
CAPACITY BY THE FORMER STATE
EMPLOYEE I WAS APPALLED THAT THE
STATE WOULD ALLOW CONTRACTORS TO
SUPERVISE CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES. CONTRACTORS WHO ARE
AT WILL EMPLOYEES HAVE NO LONG
TERM COMMITMENT TO THE STATE AND
DO NOT HAVE AS MUCH EXPERIENCE
AS SOMETHING EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
AT THE HOSPITAL MANY YEARS THE
PRACTICE OF PLACING A CONTRACTOR
IN A MANAGERIAL OR SUPERVISORY
CAPACITY IS APPALLING BECAUSE IT
DISCOURAGES UPWARD MOBILITY IN
ADDITION YOU HAVE A CONTRACTOR
OVERSEEING THE LOOK SERVICE
EMPLOYEES. MAKING DECISIONS ON
WHO TO HIRE OR FIRE CONDUCTING
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION PROVIDING
TRAINING PROVIDING DISCIPLINE
EXCEPT FOR A WHILE THE
THEMSELVES ARE FULLY OF AN
AGENCY CONTRACTED THROUGH THE
STATE AND NOT STATE EMPLOYEE. OF
THE BILL OF IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE IT CHAU CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES THE STATE VALUES THEIR
SERVICE AND WILL ENSURE. THAT
THEY WERE. ONE FOUR. POINT EIGHT
AND ALSO PER UP MOBILITY WITH
THE STATE. SO I'LL BE I HEARD A
YES VOTE ON AND I YOUR IS THE
TIME AND ALLOWING ME TO ACCESS
THE FACT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF MEASURE
AND WE HAVE. IN THE- CHAMBERS
AND SOME OF THE HALLWAYS.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR GEORGIA.
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR YOU APD
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE
WERE SOME FOLKS IN THE HALLWAY.
SUPPORT. OKAY IN THAT CASE WILL
THE PHONES OPERATOR. ONE IS ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. FOR THOSE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. A
SINGLE SUPPORT IN THE ROOM TO
TESTIFY I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE AUTHOR WELL ACTUALLY THIS IS
OPPOSITION. ANYWAY THIS IS
OPPOSITION THE ROOM. GIVE THE
PHONE LINE ANYONE IS OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE OPERATOR. WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
CARE AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IT APPEARS WE WITH THE SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. OPPOSITION GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KRISTOFF MEYER WITH ASKED ME
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. REBECCA COMMITTEE
COMMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISTER DONALD I'LL JUST WAKE
MAKE ONE CONGRESS RICHER BOB IS
GOOD BILL. I DON'T KNOW WHY WE
WOULD EVER HIRE A CONTRACTOR. TO
OVERSEE QUOTE UNQUOTE A REGULAR
EMPLOYEE- IT SEEMS IRRESPONSIBLE
CONTRACTORS NOT GOING TO BE
FAMILIAR WITH THE CULTURE OF THE
ORGANIZATION. QUITE FRANKLY NOT
THE FACILITY SO IT MAY BE A SOME
SAFETY APPLICATIONS AND BRING
SOMEONE WHO THE OUTSIDE JUST
DROPPING THEM AND SAY HEY. TODAY
YOUR MANAGER SO GOOD BILL THANK
YOU AND I WILL BE SUPPORTIVE.
THANK YOU- THE RESULT OF
COMMITTEES- I WAS WE CAN'T VOTE
ON THIS THIS THIS BILL BILL
CALL- YOU CLOSE ARAMBULA THANK
YOU WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE
I IS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. IN THIS ROOM
WITH A FILE ITEM WAS USED TO
PATTERSON AUDIENCE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY THREE. YUP. MISTER
PATTERSON MEMBERS OF THE BILL
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER MEMBERS UP. AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE IS A BILL
TO SIMPLY EXTEND WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTIONS TO THOSE YOU CONFIDE
IN THE LEGISLATURE WHETHER TO AN
INDIVIDUAL MEMBER OR A
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. MY OFFICE
HAS PERSONALLY RECEIVED NUMEROUS
COMPLAINTS FROM STATE WORKERS AT
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS. INFORMING
ME OF ISSUES AN ACTIVITY THAT
THEY CONSIDERED INAPPROPRIATE
HOWEVER THEY OFTEN FEAR FOR
THEIR JOBS AND WITHHOLD ANY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THEY DO NOT RECEIVE
ANY WHISTLE BLOWER PROTECTIONS
WHEN CONFIDING. IN THE
LEGISLATURE. CURRENTLY SECTION
EIGHT FIVE FOUR SEVEN OF THE
GOVERNMENT COAT PROTECT STATE
WORKERS FROM RETALIATION WHEN
THEY REPORT ILLEGAL OR IMPROPER
CONDUCT TO THE STATE AUDITOR OR
THE COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE. THIS INCLUDES
REPORTING UP WASTE AND FRAUD
ABUSE OF AUTHORITY VIOLATIONS OF
THE LAW OR THREATS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH WITHOUT FEAR. OF
RETRIBUTION. AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
THREE WILL EXPAND THE DEFINITION
OF THE TERM PROTECTED DISCLOSURE
TO INCLUDE INCLUDE A COMPLAINT
MADE TO THE LEGISLATURE OR A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE.
ALLOWING STATE WORKERS TO
CONFIDE IN THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE WITHOUT FEAR OF
RETALIATION. CURRENTLY NONE OF
THE QUESTEL BLOWER PROTECTIONS
OUTLAWED IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE
OR LABOR CODE SPECIFIES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OULD CONSTITUTE A
PROTECTED DISCLOSURE. THIS BILL
IMPORTANTLY DOES NOT GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE ANY INVESTIGATIVE OR
ANY ADDITIONAL POWERS BUT SIMPLY
THAT AN EMPLOYEE WOULD BE
PROTECTED FROM RETALIATION BY
THEIR EMPLOYER. UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I HAVE A- AS A
WITNESS AT THE STATE THE
EMPLOYEE COLIN GRANT HE IS ON
THE PHONE FOR HIS TESTIMONY. THE
THREAT. MISTER AT WHAT. IF I AM
HERE PLEASE PROCEED. WELL I'VE
BEEN A STATE EMPLOYEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS NOW AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I'LL FOLLOW
THE WHISTLE BLOWER COMPLAINT
WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
TO REPORT. WASTE GROSS
MISCONDUCT IN PENN- AND- IN
ADDITION THE A BY. GIVEN THE
SEVERITY OF THE SITUATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AT THE TIME THE
WHISTLE BLOWER COMPLAINT TO THE
STATE OFFICE- STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE BUT NOT ENOUGH- MY
OVERWHELMINGLY FELT THAT I
NEEDED TO CONTACT THE
LEGISLATURE AND I DID. AND I
ENDED UP TESTIFYING IN A JOINT
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT- AUDIT OF
THE DEPARTMENT WHICH WAS DO
WOULD BE TO- THE WHOLE PROCESS I
WAS COMPLETELY SURPRISED BECAUSE
I HAD NO WHISTLE BLOWER
PROTECTIONS UNDER LAW BY
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE-
BUT I DID ANYWAY BECAUSE I HAD
TO DO SOMETHING BECAUSE AS A
MANAGER YOU KNOW SEEING MY
EMPLOYEE CRYING BECAUSE THEY'RE
STILL AT WORK AT NINE O'CLOCK
AND THEY HAVE A TWO YEAR OLD AT
HOME WITH A BEARABLE FOR ME. SO
IN THAT CASE WHEN YOU AND I JUST
WENT ON AHEAD BECAUSE I FELT THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
INVOLVEMENT WITH NEEDED IN THAT
CASE AND WILL SUPPORT. WHAT ARE-
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T FEAR
INTIMIDATION COURTS AND- RIGHT
THE RETALIATION BUT THAT ONLY
APPLIES WHEN THEY REPORT THINGS
TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
AND- ON DIFFERENT SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE LIKE I SAID IT
WOULD EXTEND THE- THE PROTECTION
TO WHEN WE REPORTED THAT LEAD
PLAINTIFF WHICH I BELIEVE IS
VERY NECESSARY BECAUSE LIKE EVEN
IN THE CASE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF IT IF IT WAS PASSED WHERE.
THE STATE AUDITOR WOULD JUST BE
ABLE TO AUDIT THEM AND FIND OUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON BUT MORE
IMMEDIATE ACTION WAS NEEDED BUT
LIKE I SAID I WAS MOTIVATED TO
THE PUBLIC AT THE THINGS
DISCUSSED. VERY UNBEARABLE.
THANK YOU. THIS WITNESSES
SUPPORT THE ROOM ANYWAY THIS IS
A- SIGNAL WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. ANY WITNESSES IN A
PHONE OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE ON THE
FRONT LINES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. WHAT ABOUT WHAT ABOUT
SUPPORT OPERATOR BUT- SORRY ANY
PARTICIPANT IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN TO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS
NO ONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT FOR THE CONTINUED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BILL- FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINES THIS WOULD
OPPOSITION THE ROOM ANYBODY
OPPOSITION IS BILL THE ROOM.
BRING BACK THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WE'RE
STILL SUBCOMMITTEE SO- IT WILL
BE A QUESTION OKAY THAT'S ONE
QUESTION I'VE DUBBED AND BEEN
MADE AWARE OF AN ISSUE WHEREIN-
THIS BILL COULD MAKE- LAWMAKERS
. INDIVIDUALLY LIABLE- IF ANY.
COM IF ANY OF ANY OF ANY
PERSON'S NAME. SOMEHOW GETS
DISCLOSED YOU HAVEN'T GIVE ANY
COMMENT ON THAT. I DO THIS WELL
CAME THROUGH A JUDICIARY ON
CONSENT AND THERE WAS NOTHING
RAISED OF THAT CONCERN OKAY.
WELL IT BUT DOES IT DOES IT DO
THAT THOUGH DOES IT MAKE YOU
INTO THE LAB AT THE THAT. ALL
RIGHT BUT WE DID THAT BETTER YET
MAYBE MAYBE THE BETTER WAYS JUST
CONTEMPLATE THAT. I DON'T KNOW
WE HAVE A SOLUTION TODAY I DON'T
KNOW IF IT IS A REAL PROBLEM.
JUST KNOW THAT THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT.
THERE'S THE POTENTIAL FOR THAT
TO OCCUR AND HELP WAS THE BILL
MOST OF THE PROCESS THAT CAN BE
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THAT. WELL
I'M AT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE HEARD THAT RAISED RIGHT I'M
TELLING YOU IT'S A CONCERN. SO I
AM MAKING AWARE OF IT SO YOU DO
NOT HAVE IT. THIS THE FIRST TIME
IS THE FIRST TIME BUT JUST LET
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S A CONCERN
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT TO MANDATE
IS A THINK A LEGITIMATE CONCERN
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE NEED TO
STOP THE BAYLOR SPORTS VILLARD
BUT AGAINST THE VILLAINOUS TELL
YOU THAT THAT MAY BE A PROBLEM
GOING FORWARD TO HELP AS IT
MOVES TO THE PROCESS. THAT WILL
THIS BE CONTEMPLATED. WHAT WILL
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND- FIND
OUT. YOU KNOW WHAT. WHERE THE
CONCERN RESTS WIDE UP TO. I
THINK THERE THE BEST I CAN SAY
IS THAT THE PEERS TO BE AN
IMPLICATION OF THE BILL NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S BEST SPECIFIED
IN IT OR IN SOME WAY- RISKS A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE IT IT
IS THE- TO ME IT'S THE SAME KIND
OF WHISTLE BLOWER PROTECTION-
THAT THAT ARE IT'S GIVEN TO
OTHERS. HAVE WITH THESE OTHER
AGENCIES OR ORGANIZATIONS. AND
IN ORDER I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE'S IT'S AN UNDERCURRENT OF
CONCERN ABOUT THE LIABILITY TO
THOSE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS SEEMS
TO ME THAT THERE'S AN
IMPLICATION AND MAYBE THAT'S-
WELL IT IS. OKAY MISTER
PATTERSON WITH AT CLOSING YOUR
BILL. YEAH I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT CRUCIAL THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THERE ARE STATE
WORKERS ARE ABLE TO CONFIDE IN
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS. ABOUT
IMPROPER GOVERNMENT ACTIVITIES
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION A.
B. ONE SEVEN TWO THREE WOULD
GIVE STATE EMPLOYEES ANOTHER
AVENUE TO REPORT SUCH IMPROPER
ACTIVITIES WHILE ENSURING THEIR
JOBS ARE NOT THREATENED AND AS I
. MENTIONED EARLIER- JUDICIARY
LOOKED AT THIS THOROUGHLY AND-
FOUND NO ISSUES WITH THAT AND IT
THAT. WENT TO CONSENT AND ALSO
THIS IS A MARROW BILL. I DON'T
THINK WE WANT OUR LEGIS LATERS
TO PREP. AT ESSENTIALLY DO
AUDITS ERA IT IS INFORMATION
ATTRACTED AND THEN LEGISLATORS
HAVE THE CHOICE OF CONSIDERING
LEGISLATION OR MAY BE ASKING FOR
AN OFFICIAL AUDIT. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT. WE HAVE RECEIVED
. NUMEROUS INDIVIDUALS GOOD
STATE WORKERS WHO SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON INSIDE AND THAT THEY
HAVE CONFIDED IN US- THE DMV IS
ONE OF THEM THE EDT IS ANOTHER
AND ALSO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
THERE ARE PEOPLE GOOD PEOPLE
INSIDE THESE ORGANIZATIONS AND
THEY WANT TO BE HEARD BUT THEY
ALSO WANT TO BE PROTECTEDAND I
THINK HAVING THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICE THE LEGISLATURE. A BE
ABLE TO GRANT THAT- I THINK THE
IMPLICATION OF LIABILITY IS
SOMETHING YOU KNOW WE LOOK AT
BUT- I DON'T THINK I DON'T THINK
IT'S IMPLIED IN THE BILL AT ALL.
AND I. RESPECT AN AYE VOTE WHEN
OF THE FULL COMMITTEE. SURE IT
WILL DO THAT ONCE WE GET A
QUORUM THE DALLAS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ASSIMILATIONIST
ARRIVED. NEXT UP IS A NUMBER
FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE
- MISTER SHEFFIELD BREEZE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AS WELL
AS YOUR TEAM'S COMMITMENT TO
HELPING OUR THIS BILL- I WOULD
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
THREE. AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
THREE ONE IS FOR THE FINANCIAL
SECURITY. OF RETIRED SWORN PEACE
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS
WISEMAN THEIR ENTIRE CAREERS
PROTECTING AND SERVING. DO YOU
THINK EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS WHERE COUNTY
MISINTERPRETING LOS THE
FINANCIAL LIVELIHOOD OF RETIREES
IS BEING CHALLENGED BY THE
THREAT OF SUDDEN CALL BACKS.
WITH MY DISTRICT CAPTAIN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY
RETIRED DUE TO JOB RELATED
INJURIES IN TWENTY TWENTY AFTER
THIRTY YEARS OF SERVICE. HE
RECENTLY WAS CONTACTED BY THE
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM- NOTED SO
SERVICE WAS TOLD HE'S GOING TO
BE REQUIRED TO PAY THE SYSTEM
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ELEVEN
THOUSAND. TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TAKE A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN HIS MONTHLY
RETIREMENT GOING FORWARD. DUE TO
ON CALL PAY BEING DISALLOWED.
FOR DECADES THE COUNTY BOARD THE
NORMAL CONTRIBUTION. TO ORANGE
COUNTY EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM WHICH HISTORICALLY
INCLUDED ON CALL PAY AND CANINE
HAMMER PAINT. I JULY THIRTIETH
TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT CHAMPAGNE IN WHAT IS KNOWN
AS THE ALAMEDA CASE IN HIS
DECISION. THE COURT DETERMINED
THAT THE VOLUNTARY ON CALL PAVE
WAS NOT COMPENSATION OR NOBLE IN
NEED WITH K. NINE HANDLER PAID.
EVER SALT CLOSER STATED ITS
INTENT TO CLAW BACK ANY PAYMENTS
MADE TO RETIREES FOR ON CALL OR
CANINE HANDLER PAY. LOCK OVER
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
PRESENT AND REDUCE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS GOING FORWARD FOR
RETIREES. WILL HAVE AFFECTED
REDUCING SOME RETIREES MONTHLY
PAYMENTS BY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
RATHER JUST APPLYING THIS TO YOU
RETIREES. THIS CREATES A
SUBSTANTIAL HARDSHIP RETIREES.
THAT BUDGET BASED ON A FIXED
INCOME. THE FINANCIAL I WILL
HAVE FIREFIGHTERS AND PEACE
OFFICERS SHOULD NOT BE
DETERMINED BY REPORTING ERROR
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THE
EMPLOYEES. AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
THREE ONE SURE THAT IF A
REPORTING ERROR IS TO OCCUR
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THE EMPLOYEE
THAT THE ONUS WE PLACE UPON THE
EMPLOYER TO ENSURE THAT THESE
RETIREES FOR SMALL PORTION OF
THE FUTURE PENSION AMOUNTS THAT
THEY WERE PROMISE. WE ARE
DETERMINED TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL
THROUGHOUT ITS LIFE TO FIND A
RESOLUTION FOR THE CONCERNING
PROVISION. NOTATING COMMITTEE
AND ITS ANALYSIS HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH ME WE HAVE MR DUCKS REVERSE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS MISTER
SHANE LEVINE REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSPECTIVES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT- THE CPF
REPRESENTS MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS- AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONNEL
ACROSS THE STATE- MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS- RELY ON A SECURE
RETIREMENT FROM A NINETEEN
THIRTY SEVEN AT COUNTY
RETIREMENT SYSTEM- IN. LAST YEAR
THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT A MEASURE
SB TWO SEVEN EIGHT BY SENATOR
CENTER LEYVA THE PROVIDE
PROTECTION FOR DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION- AT FOR MEMBERS
THAT RELY ON CALPERS FOR THEIR
SECURITIZED. WE THINK THAT THIS
MEASURE WILL BRING PARITY AND
PROTECTION FOR DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION TO- OUR MEMBERS
LIKE THE FIREFIGHTER THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD REFERENCED
AND IN HIS OPENING- LIKE MANY
RETIREES WHEN- OVER FIREFIGHTER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER RETIRES
THEY RELY ON A FIXED MONTHLY
PENSION TO MAKE THEIR DAY TO DAY
NEEDS. AND UNLIKE MANY STEP A
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES MANY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES INCLUDING A
SIZEABLE PERCENTAGE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL DO NOT. RECEIVE
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS SO FOR
pMONTHLY PENSION IS OUR ONLY
SOURCE OF INCOME AND WHEN THEIR
NOTICE THAT THEY HAVE A
DISALLOWED- BUT PAY ITEM THAT IS
DISALLOWED THEN HAVE THIS
CONSIDERABLE OVERPAYMENT THAT
THEY HAVE TO REPAY AND A
REDUCTION IN THE RETIREMENT HAS
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THEIR-
ON THEIR ON THEIR LIFE AND THEIR
RETIREMENT SO FOR THOSE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. THE THIS
CHAIRMAN MACHINE LEVINE- ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION ORANGE
COUNTY DE SHERIFFS ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE. LET ME
JUST FIRST BEGIN BY SAYING WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE- THE CHURN STAFF ON
RESOLVING ANY- ANY ISSUES AROUND
PROPOSED A IN THE BILL- THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP IN THE ANALYSIS ALL.
BEGIN WITH THAT. AGAIN MY WAY
BACKGROUND FOR DECADES COUNTY
ORANGE PAID THE NORMAL
CONTRIBUTION- SERVICE WHICH IS
DIRECTLY INCLUDED ON CALL PAY IN
CANINE HANDLER PASSED. THESE
ITEMS HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED BY
OFFICERS TO BE PART OF THE
COMPENSATION HERBAL CALCULATION
AS SUCH PORTIONS OF THE EMPLOYER
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTION IN THE
EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS WERE ATTRIBUTABLE.
TO ON CALL IN CANINE HANDLER
PAY. ON JULY THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE COURT THIS CALPERS
BRING FOR ISSUED WHAT IS KNOWN
AS THE ALAMEDA DECISION. THE
COURT DETERMINED THAT VOLUNTARY
ON CALL PAY WAS NOT COMPENSATION
OR DOUBLE AND NEITHER WAS CANINE
HANDLER PAY AND AS A RESULT
OSTER STATED ITS INTENT TO CLAW
BACK ANY PAYMENTS MADE TO
RETIREES FOR ON CALL. FOR CANINE
HANDLER PAY FROM OCTOBER FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY THROUGH THE
PRESENT. IN TO REDUCE THOSE
MONTHLY PAYMENTS GOING FORWARD
FOR RETIREES. TO EXCLUDE THESE
PAYS WHICH WILL HAVE THE EFFECT
OF REDUCING SOME RETIREES
MONTHLY INCOME. BY THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
THIS IS A CRITICAL STEP. IN AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE TO HELP
WRITE A SIGNIFICANT WRONG AS WE
SEE IT WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
RETIREES BECAUSE OF THIS
DECISION. MEMBERS OF OUR
DEPARTMENT WHO WORKED THEIR
CAREERS AND HIGH PROFILE UNITS
SUCH AS HOMICIDE BOMB SQUAD
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS
CANINE AND OTHER SPECIALIZED
UNITS. WITHIN THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE GAVE UP
VALUABLE FAMILY TIME DURING
EVENINGS HOLIDAYS AND WEEKENDS
IN ORDER TO REMAIN AVAILABLE. TO
MEDIATE WILL RESPOND WITHIN
POLICY TO WORK WHEN CALLED UPON.
MEMBERS THESE MEN AND WOMEN DID
THEIR JOB AS THEY WERE REQUIRED
AND REQUESTED AND IN RETURN THEY
WERE PROMISED TO GUARANTEED WAGE
AND GUARANTEED INCOME IN
RETIREMENT. TO NOW BE TOLD BY
THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM THERE WAS
A MISTAKE IN THIS WAS A MISTAKE
IN THIS MISTAKE IS TO BE BORNE
BY THEM. THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN IS AN INJUSTICE. THE
EMPLOYEES ARE BASICALLY BEING
TOLD NOW THEY WORK FOR A
DISCOUNT. THE EMPLOYER I WOULD
ARGUE STANDS TO GAIN A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL WINDFALL BECAUSE
THIS PROPOSITION. THEY
ULTIMATELY GET THE BENEFIT OF
THIS BARGAIN. HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF RETIREES NOW STAND
TO LOSE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN RETIREMENT NOT
ONLY FROM CLAWBACKS BUT ON THE
GO FORWARD. IT'S SIMPLY NOT
RIGHT. WITHOUT AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
FOR HIS TIME AND THOUGHTFULNESS
RUNS ISSUE IN THE CHURCH AND-
MISTER CHAIR- YOUR HELP AS WELL.
WITH THAT WE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
HONEY BE TWENTY FOUR NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE ON THE ROOM. SINGLE
WITH THE PHONE LINE WITH US IS
SUPPORT OPERATOR. AT SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FOR A MOMENT THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JAMES BIRCH
STREET AND WHAT. CALORE CHE-
BURKE WHEN I SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. FOR AN EXCURSION. FOR
IT FOR LISTENERS RUN OTHER
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY THREE AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU AND OUR
NEXT PERSON IN LINE THIRTY TWO
OKAY OKAY. YES I'M CAROLYN
HUDSON AND CAL ARCHIE EIGHT.
AREA NINE AND THAT THE KEY BILL
I JUST WANT TO SAY I SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WELL MOVED
UP- FOLKS IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. WILL MOVE
BACK TO OUR PHONE LINES OPERATOR
ANYONE THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU ANYONE
IS IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE ARE NO LINES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE. REMEMBER THAT
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
WHICH THE VEHICLE OF. SERVER TO
MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT THE
CHURCH WOULD LIKE TO START OFF
BY SAYING- YOUR STAFF IS
INCREDIBLE ESPECIALLY WAS
REMARKABLE AND WHOSE WORK REALLY
CLOSELY WITH MYSELF MR SHIVERS
INSERTION LEVINE AS WELL AS-
MILLAGE DIRECTORIES YOU SWIMMER
IN TERMS OF THE UNDERSTANDING
AND AS WELL AS THE ANALYSIS OF
THE BILL SO I WANT TO SAY MY
HAT'S OFF TO YOU. FURTHERMORE AS
A FORMER DEPUTY SHERIFF I JOIN
TO BECOME RESERVISTS HAVE TO BE
LIKE MY HEROES LIKE PEOPLE SUCH
AS YOURSELF WITHIN A LIFETIME
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THROUGH THAT
TIME I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET WITH MANY INDIVIDUALS ONE
SUCH INDIVIDUALS EIGHT-
INDIVIDUAL A BOMB SQUAD IN L. A.
COUNTY AND DAY HE'S GONNA BOMB
SQUAD FOR OVER. AND HE REFERRED
FROM TAKING MANY PROMOTIONS IN
ORDER TO STAY IN THE BOMB SQUAD
AND HE HAD A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
TO GET PROMOTED BE CHOSE NOT TO
AND BECAUSE OF THAT- AND WITH
THE ALAMEDA CASE HE'S BEEN
PUNISHED FOR THAT SO IT IS MY
HOPE THAT WITH THIS BILL AND
WITH FURTHER ANALYSIS AND
CAREFUL ANALYSIS THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THEM MORE HOLD. ON AND I
ASSURE YOU THAT IN THE EVENT
THAT THERE IS SOME ISSUES WITH
THIS BILL WILL BE HAPPY TO BRING
THIS BACK TO PUBLIC SAFETY- BUT
I BELIEVE THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN BE RESOLVED AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THANK. YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. I WAS VERY WILL. IN
ABOUT THE SQUAD BOB. THAT
RESPOND SKULLS- THE PARTIES
INVEST HUNDREDS OF. DOLLAR AND
TRAIN. IN THE TAKES YEARS TO GET
EXPERTISE AND SOME FOLKS MOVED
LETTER PROMOTE. AND THEY WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THEIR- THE
PENSION THE CORRECT PENSION
BECAUSE THESE FOLKS CHOSE. TO-
THE LIFELINE AND DO ASSIGNMENTS
LIKE THIS OTHER PENALIZED FOR
THIS SO OVERALL I AGREE WITH
WITH THE AUTHORS TRYING TO DO
HERE TO PROTECT THESE RETIREES.
BUT ALSO CONCERNS REGARDING THE
RETRACTOR PROVISION IN THIS BILL
LET'S TALK ABOUT AT LENGTH IN
THE ANALYSIS. AND WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL AS IT IS IN PROVIDING
HIGH RECOMMENDATION. BOTH A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH COMMITTEE STAFF TO
FIND ALTERNATIVE TO THE
CONCERNING PROVISION. OR RULE
PULLED THIS BILL BACK THIS
COMMITTEE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME- WE'RE STILL SUBCOMMITTEE
SO THE APPROPRIATE TIME OF A
QUORUM OVER IN YOUR BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER FOR TIME THANK YOU
MISTER. I SEE MISTER LONELY OFF
. IN THE US. ACTUALLY FLAMIN LOW
- NEXUS I REMEMBER SEVEN AB.
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX. MISTER
LOPEZ PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY AND ALSO SEE. W. WITNESSES.
THE YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIR COME
MEMBERS IT'S AN ABSOLUTE HONOR
TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX
WHICH ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS
HAVE TIME TO CELEBRATE AND
RECOGNIZE ASIAN CULTURE AND
RECOGNIZE THE FABRIC OF AMERICAN
DIVERSITY BY MAKING LUNAR NEW
YEAR. THEN YOUR DAY A STATE
HOLIDAY. MISTER CHAIR YOU'VE
BEEN INCREDIBLE CHAMPION AN ALLY
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY IN RESPONSE
TO STOPPING ASIAN ZONDER HATE
THIS FALLS IN THAT SPIRIT OF
HELPING TO UPLIFT OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES IT WITH RESPECT TO
RECOGNIZING. THEIR CULTURAL
FABRIC OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE SAME TIME THIS
HELPS TO HELP PROMOTE THE
VISIBILITY AND CULTURE TO
TRADITIONS OF SO MANY WITHIN THE
ASIA PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
. FINALLY MAY ALSO JUST SAY THAT
THERE ARE NONE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALREADY
RECOGNIZED LUNAR NEW YEAR AS A
HOLIDAY AND HELPING TO REFLECT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT
SIGNIFICANCE AS WELL TO.
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS ENJOYS A
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE AND APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THAT
REGARD WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
INSTITUTE EDITION OF WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT WHO CAN ALSO TESTIFY.
AT IN. ITS ADVOCACY FOR THE
LEGISLATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU I SEE S.
COUNSELOR STEPHANIE WHITMAN
THREE WILL GROWTH. ARE YOU VICE
MAYOR IT'S AT JUST FINISH MY
TERM AS VICE MAYOR SIR SO BACK
TO COUNCIL MEMBER FOR YOUR
CUSTOMERS LESS CITIES OF THIS
PROCEED YES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND I WANT TO COMMAND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A LITTLE FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. I AM VERY
FORTUNATE TO BE AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT STARTED DURING
THE FALL OF SAIGON WHEN WE HAD
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES COME TO THIS
COUNTRY AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THE ONE HOLIDAY THE ONE DAY IN
WHICH WE CELEBRATED. AND WE SEE
MUCH SO HELD CLOSE OUR HEART WAS
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR AND THAT WAS
THE DAY IN WHICH WE CAN
CELEBRATE WITH EACH OTHER HONOR
OUR ANCESTORS BUT ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO THE FUTURE AND LET ME
JUST PAUSE THERE FOR A SECOND.
BECAUSE AS ASIANS WE TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENS AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE LUNAR NEW YEAR AND THAT
DICTATES WHAT HAPPENS FOR THE
REST OF THE YEAR. LUNAR NEW YEAR
IS NOT JUST THE DAY THAT WE
CELEBRATE IT'S A WEEK LONG
PREPARATION. CLEANING THE HOUSE
MAKING SURE EVERYTHING. IS IN
PLACE. THAT AN APPLE NOT A DAY.
BUT MORE IN. I WILL AT THIS. IS
A MATTER. I CELEBRATE BAD.
KARELIANS CELEBRATE THE LUNAR
NEW YEAR AND I'M TIRED OF
FOCUSING HAPPY CHINESE NEW YEAR
TO ME. I'M SURE OTHERS LIKE THE
KOREAN AMERICAN AND THE MILLION
AMERICANS ARE TIRED OF HEARING
FOLKS SAY. HAPPY CHINESE NEW
YEAR NOTHING AGAINST OUR CHINESE
AMERICAN LEADER HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVEL BUT IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
EDUCATE OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
CHILDREN AS WELL TO YOU. YOU CAN
BE THE FIRST HERE. IN THE STATE.
ALL ACROSS THE UNITED STATES TO
RECOGNIZE THIS HOLIDAY AND SET
EXAMPLE FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD I
HOPE THAT WE CAN GET YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS THANK YOU. THE
PLACE IS COULD A LOT OF FOLKS
WATCHING ON TV. GOOD MORNING
ARMCHAIR COOPER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS OPERATE
NEEDED MONEY PERCENT AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER OF THE LESION THE ASIAN
PACIFIC AMERICAN LABOR ALLIANCE
A LOT. OF TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX- FOR MANY ASIAN AMERICANS.
AT THAT HOUSE A WOMAN- GENSET
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT DAY IN THEIR CULTURAL
TRADITIONS IS NOT JUST THE DATE
THAT THAT HOW FAR OFF IS THE
DATE THAT THEY SHOW RESPECT FOR
THE ELDERLY THE PARENTS THEIR
GRANDPARENTS. AND SHOW THEIR
LOVE FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND ALSO
TO REMEMBER THEIR ANCESTORS THEY
SPEND A LOT OF TIME YOU KNOW-
REMEMBERING THEIR ANCESTORS WITH%
A WHOLE BUNCH OF RITUALS AND
THEY SPEND TIME WITH THEIR
FAMILIES- DURING MY CHILDHOOD
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR WAS SO
IMPORTANT THAT MY WORKING CLASS
PARENTS. WHO WATCH THEIR STORE
THIRTEEN HOURS A DAY I MEAN IT
THIRTEEN HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS
A WEEK THREE HUNDRED AND. THIRTY
THREE DAYS A YEAR THIRTY TWO
DAYS A YEAR. BUT THEY WOULD
CLOSE. OUR STORE FOR THREE FULL
DAYS WHY BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY
VERY IMPORTANT HOLIDAYFOR OUR
TRADITIONS- WITH THE CHINESE
WORKERS CONTRIBUTION CRUCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE SUCCESSFUL
CONSTRUCTION OF THE TRANS
COUNTRY. TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD. AND THAT LABOR
EXPLOITATION THEY DIDN'T THAT
CHINESE WORKERS IN. AND THE HMM
WORKERS CRITICAL ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. IT IS AN
EQUITY ISSUE IN MY OPINION IT IS
AN EQUITY ISSUE THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS ASIAN WORKERS NEED TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN CELEBRATING THEIR
CULTURAL TRADITIONS AND WORK OR
SCHOOL. STUDENTS I TEACH AT
AMERICAN RIVERCOLLEGE AS WELL
AB STUDENTS WHO REALLY HAVE TO
LOOK OUT TORN BETWEEN WHAT TO DO
SCHOOL WHAT THEIR TRADITIONS I
DON'T THINK THAT'S EQUITABLE-
HOUSING IT BE TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX. IS ONE WAY TO A QUICKLY
HONORED ASIAN WORKERS UP ITS
STATE. ONE IN THREE ASIAN
AMERICANS LIVE IN THIS GREAT
STATE A COUPLE OF ONE. PLEASE
PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING AGAIN TURN
MEMBERS KRISTOFF MEYER WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MINUTES MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX. THIS IS
YOUR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CINEMA THIS IS
ONE OF THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR
ANYWAY THIS IS A SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE.
OPERATOR. WE LOST THE OPERATOR.
WE'RE GONNA WITNESSES OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM. ANYONE IS NOT
POSITION IN THE ROOM. I THINK
THAT'LL COME BACK TO THE
OPERATOR AGAIN OPERATOR YOU
THERE. KIDS BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
MITCHELL DONALD. YEAH MAYBE ONE
OF THEWITNESSES CAN EDUCATE ME
BECAUSE I'M NOT AS FAMILIAR WITH
THIS IS SOME OTHERS IN THE ROOM
ARE FOR SURE- BUT YOU WHAT YOU
WANT TO CALL THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
RIGHT NOT THE CHINESE NOT THE
CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR NOT. TO HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY LONG BEACH THAT IS
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS CALL THE
CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR THAT THEY DO
BUT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS YOU
WANT TO CALLED LUNAR NEW YEAR
AND ANYTHING SIR IT DEPENDS ON
YOUR AUDIENCE I'M SORRY NINETY
COMPANIES. IT'S ON YOUR IDEA A
FOR THE- CARE. WE CALL IT THAT.
AND THE CHINESE NEW YEAR THEY
CALL IT CHINESE NEW YEAR- BUT
THE CAMBODIAN THEY WOULD CALL IT
CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR WE- WE DON'T
CALL VIETNAMESE NEW YEAR WE CALL
IT'S KNOWN AS BAD BREAK. BUT
WHEN YOU SAY LUNAR NEW YEAR AND
THEN IT COVERS ALL OF. THE
UMBRELLA YEAH THERE'S A- FEW OF
US THAT CELEBRATE THISGOT IT.
AND IF I MAY ADD THAT GREW UP IN
THAILAND- YOU KNOW CHINESE
FAMILY. A CHINESE. SO IT I AM A
CHINESE THAI BEFORE IT BECAME A
CHINESE THAI AMERICANS- THIS
HOLIDAY IS CELEBRATED PRICE. ANY
DIFFERENT GROUPS IN ASIA. THAT
IT'S JUST FAIR TO CALL IT LUNAR
NEW YEAR. THANK YOU VERY. AND I
GUESS IF YOU LOOK MY NAME THERE.
YOU CAN TELL I MIGHT HAVE A BILL
NEXT TO GIVE US ST PATRICK'S DAY
OFF. OR MAYBE THE DAY AFTER I
DON'T KNOW WHICH WILL HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THAT- BUT NO I'VE I
APPRECIATE THIS NETWORK. YOU
SUPPORT. YEAH. OKAY IT'S HARD
IT'S HARD ON THAT BUT- OBVIOUSLY
WE ARE OF US IN THE LOT OF THESE
EDUCATE SO WHEN YOU CAN TEACH
EDUCATOR SOMETHING NEW THAT'S A
DAY. MR LOW. YOUR BILL. SURE
THEY DO VERY AT RISK OF PLEASE
AT AS A CALL. AND ODOM- ON THE
PROPOSED I JUST- SHOULD. COME TO
FRUITION. AND I ALSO WANT TO.
REAFFIRM THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
DYNAMIC COMMUNITY AND- YOU'VE
SEEN FROM OUR STRONG ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED- AFFECT THEM. MISTER
WHEN YOU SHOULD JUST BE HERE IN
THE SIMPLY TO PRESENT YOURSELF
AND SO STRONG IN THAT REGARD-
BUT YOU WOULD YOU SEE HERE IS
THAT THE SERVICE UNDER
COMMUNITIES NOT MONOLITHIC OF I
AM OF CHINESE DESCENT VIETNAMESE
THAI CHINESE AND THERE'S SO MANY
MORE KAMBONI AND ALL COMMITTEES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO LEAD
BY EXAMPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZING THE
STRENGTH OF OUR DIVERSITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL WHEN YOU
REACH TO COURT SURE SO WE'RE
STILL OF A SUB COMMITTEE SO WE
RICHEST WILL- DO IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO WE'RE GOING TO FILE
ORDER- NEXT UP IS I NEVER FOR A
BI. NINETEEN TWENTY ONE. MISTER
JONES SAWYER. THE TROUBLEMAKER.
HEHE YOU PREFER PRESENT THE BILL
WHEN YOU'RE READY MISTER JONES
SAWYER ABOUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
READ THAT AB NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH WILL ENCOURAGE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS TO RECEIVE
ANNUAL MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATIONS
CONDUCTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMANS RESOURCES REQUIRES THAT
EVERY OFFICER BE PROVIDED WITH
INFORMATION ON ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES THEY CAN ASSESS
UNDER EXISTING LAW ALL PEACE
OFFICERS MIND UNDERGO A PRE
EMPLOYMENT MENTAL HEALTH
SCREENING TO ENSURE THEY ARE
FREE OF ANY CONDITIONS THAT
WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO PERFORM ESSENTIAL JOB
DUTIES HOWEVER DESPITE REGULAR
EXPOSURE TO VIOLENCE AND ONE AND
ONE IN EVERY THREE OFF. IT'S A
SYSTEM OF PTSD POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER THERE IS NO
OBLIGATION FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO RECEIVE FOLLOW UP AT ANY TIME
WHEN THE SUICIDE RATES ARE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE 39%
HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION AND CORRECTION
OFFICERS ARE REPORTING THEY WANT
TO LEARN HOW TO COPE WITH PTSD
BUT- FEARFUL OF REPERCUSSIONS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING. EARLY IDENTIFICATION IS
THE KEY TO PREVENTING MORE
SERIOUS CONDITIONS MANAGING
SYSTEMS AND IMPROVING TREATMENT
OUTCOMES BY ENCOURAGING REGULAR
EVALUATIONS FOR ALL CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AB NINETEEN ONE FOR THE
WELL BEING OF OFFICERS
THEMSELVES BUT ALSO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY ALL STAFF AND INMATES
IN CALIFORNIA'S CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEMS I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPROVE THE BILL
LANGUAGE WHICH INCLUDES TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION THE EXISTING
CAL HR EMPLOYEE ASSISTANT
PROGRAM FOR CORRECTION OFFICERS.
I AM HONORED AND- HE SHOULD.
TAKE A PICTURE. OF BECAUSE WITH
ME TODAY PROVIDE TESTING OVER
PHONE. IT MATTHEW EASILY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
NO NAOMI PETRONE ON BEHALF OF
CCPOA BENEFIT TRUST RESPECT TO
ANSWERABLE THANK YOU THREE TO
PAUSE RIGHT NOW OF A QUORUM SO
WE WILL ESTABLISH A FORM. THAT
OF SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE COOPER PRESENT COOPER
PRESENT VOEPEL CALDERON. FOR
THEIR OWN PRESENT RODRIGUEZ.
WELL DONALD O'DONNELL PRESENT
SEYARTO. THEY ARE TO PRESENT. WE
SHOULD NOW. SO WHY I HAVE SOME
FOLKS ARE GONNA OF ON SOME THE
ITEMS SO. OKAY MAKE THAT LATER
ON WHAT YEAH WHAT OKAY THANK YOU
. MISTER DO SAWYER- YOUR PARTNER
WILL IN SUPPORT. OF MATTHEW E.
IT'S ON PHONE IN NAOMI TO BE A
THE LIST ARE USUALLY.
THE. WE HAVE HOPE PROBLEMS
EARLIER SO OPERATE IT AND THAT
WE COULD HAVE BEEN A PUBLIC
SAFETY WE'VE BEEN HAVING PHONE
PROBLEMS ALSO OKAY SO I
UNDERSTAND. OKAY SO IT WILL GO
UP WITH THIS IS SUPPORT THE ROOM. MORNING MISTER CHAIR GEORGE
OSBORNE FOR THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYMORE
WITH THIS IS A SUPPORT. WHAT IS
OPPOSITION TO THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE OF A BACK TO THE PHONE LINE
OPERATOR ANYWAY THIS IS SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. I THINK A FULL
ONE STILL DOUBTS ALL BRING BACK
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS. HOW
DID YOU BRING THIS BILL FORWARD
I THINK IT'S MUCH NEEDED WITHIN
THE- DEATH RATE OF OUR-
CHRISTIAN AUTHORS YOU SAID
SPIKE. AND IS STARTING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND REALLY MIL HEALTH
EVERYWHERE BUT ESPECIALLY WITH
THESE FOLKS SO THANKS FOR BEING
A PHARMACY JONES SAWYER- RESULT
OF CLOTHES IN YOUR BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. AND ONCE WITH THE
MEMBERSHIP OF WHAT. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF
THE RIVER WITH A QUORUM SORRY.
SO IS OUR MOTION. FOR YOU CAN. I
CAN GO FIRST THE SECOND-
SECRETARY WILL HELP THE MISSION
IS DEEPER AND BE REFER TO THE
ON. COULD I COULD I VOEPEL
BECAUSE- COMMENT ON I RODRIGUEZ
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I THEY ARE
TWO THE BILL AND CULTIVATES THE
LOCAL THANK YOU THANK YOU. I AND
IF WE HAVE AB SIX. I'M SORRY I
TO SIX AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR MISTER CALL. A MISTER KALRA
YOU REPRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
OF LIKE TO THINK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THE ANALYSIS. AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR WOULD GIVE
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS AT SANTA
CLARITA SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THE-
OPTION TO MOVE UNDER THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD.
JURISDICTION TO RESOLVE UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE COMPLAINTS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW TRANSITORY
AUTHORITIES LIKE BEACH YOU HAVE
TO GO TO THE SUPERIOR COURT
RESOLVE UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CHARGES. UNFORTUNATELY OUR
COURTS ARE COURTS ARE
OVERBURDENED AND UNDER FUNDED
PARTICULARLY DURING. THE
PANDEMIC SO PROCESSING YOU LP
CLAIMS CAN BE A TIME CONSUMING
AND COSTLY EFFORT OFTEN TAKING
YEARS TO RESOLVE. AND
CONTRIBUTING TO WORKPLACE
TENSIONS. AB TWENTY BY TWENTY
FOUR WOULD PROVIDE VGA EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS ACCESS TO AN
EXISTING AND A PATIENT
RESOLUTION RESOURCE THROUGH PER
THAT IS FOCUSED ON RESOLVING
OUTSTANDING PUBLIC EMPLOYER.
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS CONFLICTS
THIS BILL WOULD ADD BJ THE LIKES
OF SOCCER T. L. A. METRO PARK
POLICE SEE AND MOST PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS. WHOSE EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATIONS ALREADY HAVE THIS
OPTION WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IN PERSON IS TINA ACREE
FROM ASKING LOCAL ONE A ONE A
BUSINESS AGENT FROM ETA. AND
TAMMY TO NOTICE ON THE PHONE S.
YEAH YOU FIVE TWO ONE ALSO A
BUSINESS AGENT OF COURSE TO BE
TA THANK YOU. FOR THE- GET UP
INTO THE CHAIR COMMITTEE MAY MY
IS TEAM CREE I AM THE- BUSINESS
AGENT FOR A- ELEVEN A ONE. IN
THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS ASKED ME
HAS FILED DOZENS OF GRIEVANCES
WITH THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY URGING
THEM TO ADDRESS DEEP SEATED.
WORKPLACE ISSUES SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES HAVE CONTINUED ON FOR
YEARS WITHOUT BEING ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSED UNRESOLVED WORKPLACE
ISSUES DIRECTLY CONTRIBUTE TO
THE HOSTILE WORK ENVIRONMENT. AS
EMPLOYEES ARE LEFT TO FEEL
DISREGARDED AND DESPONDENT WHEN
THEY'RE VALID CONCERNS AROUND
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS OR
MISTREATMENT BY MANAGEMENT ARE
NOT. THIS HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT WHAT CITED BY MANY
EMPLOYEES IN THE WAKE OF THE VTA
WORKSITE SHOOTING LAST MAY THAT
LEFT NINE EMPLOYEES DEAD. YET
PROBLEMS ARE STILL NOT BEING
ADDRESSED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
ASPIN HAS NOT FILED SEVERAL-
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICES THAT WERE
SUSTAINABLE. AND VALID AS WE DO
NOT HAVE THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. TO PURSUE
THOSE CASE IS IN COURT. VTA
CURRENTLY EMPLOYS TEN IN HOUSE
ATTORNEYS WHOSE SALARIES ARE
PAID BY TAXPAYERS IN COMPARISON
TO ASK ME LOCAL ELEVEN A ONE WE
HAVE ZERO ATTORNEYS ON STAFF AND
MUST CAREFULLY BUDGET. OUR
MEMBERSHIP DUES AND ASSESS
WHETHER. LANE AGAINST VTA BASED
ON OUR LOCAL FINANCES AS A
RESULT THE DISTRICT IS NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR VALID YOU WILL
PIECE DUE TO THE FINANCIAL
CONSTRAINTS OF OUR LOCAL BY
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES ORGANIZATIONS
OF VTA TO MOVE. TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD VTA
AND ITS EMPLOYEES WILL BE ABLE
TO ASSESS THE MORE FAIR AND
TIMELY CONFLICT RESOLUTION
PROCESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I AM AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WILL MOVE
YOUR APARTMENT IS ON THE PHONE
NOW OPERATOR. IT WE HAVE LINE
THIRTY ONE LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME A
FAMILY DINNER AND I AM THE
REGION ONE VICE PRESIDENT OF
SEIU LOCAL FIVE TWO ONE AND
CHAIRPERSON OF RBGH CHAPTER AND
IT BECAME CLEAR FOR TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS. AND MY CAPACITY WITH SEIU
I NAVIGATE BOTH SUPERIOR COURT
SYSTEM AND THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS BOARD IN THE COURT
SYSTEM THE WEALTHY COMPLAINTS
ARE USUALLY A SIGN WITH WITH. NO
EXPERIENCE. IN LABOR LAW. BUT A
LOT OF JUDGES AND CON.
SPECIALIZED EMPLOY AN- RELATIONS
AND A PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT LAW. THE
COURT PRACTICE CAN TAKE YEARS TO
RESOLVE THE EUROPEAN FALL
TENSIONS REMAIN BETWEEN THE
WORKERS AND THE DISTRICT. IN
CONTRAST HAS REDUCED ITS BACKLOG
TO LESS THAN TEN CASES. ACCESS
TO FASTER PROCESS WILL GO A LONG
WAY TO RELIEVE THE TENSION AND
HOSTILE WORK ENVIRONMENT THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN RESOLVED. SERVICE
ALSO LESS EXPENSIVE PROCESS
SAVING MONEY FOR BOTH THE UNIONS
AND THE TAXPAYERS TO FUND BTA.
DOES NOT GUARANTEE WENT FOR THE
CHARGING UNION AND THE DISTRICT
WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO ABOUT
GRIEVANCES AGAINST UNIONS FOR
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICES. IT'S A
TWO WAY STREET TOWARDS
ACCOUNTABILITY OUR COMMUNITY
DESERVES THE TRANSIT AGENCIES
WITH. A FISHING THING IS NOT
BOGGED DOWN BY UNRESOLVED ISSUES
OUR COMMUNITY DESERVES
ACCOUNTABILITY. I THANK YOU
MEMBERS HAVE STRUGGLED WITH A
HOT STYLE AND TOXIC WORK
ENVIRONMENT FOR MANY YEARS THAT
EACH YEAR. FOR EXAMPLE ARE LIGHT
WILL SIGNAL MAINTAINERS SHOP
BEING IN THE SAME BUILDING WHERE
THE MASS SHOOTING OCCURRED
ELEVEN MONTHS AGO. HAS BEEN SO
PROBLEMATIC FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS THAT LED TO TWO OF OUR
FOOT IN THE MAINTAINER FILING
RESTRAINING. ORDERS AGAINST EACH
OTHER AND CIVIL COURT. AB HER AS
A OPTION COMPANIES.
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR BOTH SIDES
WILL HELP BUILD TRUST INCREASE
PROMOTE HARMONY IN THE
WORKPLACE. AND WE NEED
DESPERATELY NEED THIS AT BTA.
PLEASE PASS AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR TWO GRAMMY T. UNION
ACCESS TO THE SAME CONCEPT.
PUBLIC RESOLUTION. PROCESS THE
BILL. OVER 80% OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND
I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THE YOU WE'RE GOOD WITH THIS IS
A SUPPORT OF THE ROOM. KRISTOFF
MEYER WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WE ARE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOW ACOSTA WAS
SMART TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
STATE LEGISLATIVE BOARD IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT REMOVE THE WITNESSES
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OPERATOR.
FOR THOSE AREN'T SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO NINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MIND FIFTEEN. HELLO JAMES
ANNABLE ON BEHALF OF SMART LOCAL
TWENTY THREE AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER WITNESSES. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NOW REMOVED WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION THE ROOM. SEEING NONE
WILL MOVED OPPOSITIONS WITNESSES
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OPERATOR
. IT'S PAST ONE OF THEM ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION. LINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN AT
NINE THIRTY ONE. I APOLOGIZE MY
APOLOGIES- CHAIR MEMBERS WITH
THE JENNIFER MALLINCKRODT'S THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I
WAS ACTUALLY KICKED OUT OF THE
QUEUE WE ARE IN THE PARK AND-
APPRECIATE. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO OTHER WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
LINE THANK YOU OPERATOR WILL
BRING BACK COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS I DON'T THINK AUTHOR
BRING THIS FOR THIS IMPORTANT
BILL- DURING MY TIME OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE SHOULD A LOT OF
BILLS COME FORWARD WERE IT IS
THE- FIGHTING BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THE COURTS ARE VERY EXPENSIVE
AND COST A LOT OF MONEY AND
PROVIDES A MUCH- FASTER ROUTE
AND LESS EXPENSIVE SO I THINK
IT'S MUCH NEEDED AND- IT'S A
GOOD BILL. OUR MOTION. WELL
MOTION A SECOND- SWIMMER KALRA
WITHOUT CLOSING YOUR BILL WOULD
USE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS MY
CLOTHES THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE OKAY
MEL SECRETARY. LOCAL POLICE. THE
MOTION IS THE PERSON REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON A PURPOSE
COOPER HI COOPER I WILL TELL
CALDERON CALDERON AYE RODRIGUEZ
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I SEYARTO
THE BILL IS ON CALL WITH THREE
VOTES. THANK YOU. WE'VE GOT THE
TWO BILLS REMAINING THEY'RE BOTH
LINES STRUGGLE YOU TOOK OVER AS
CHAIR THANK YOU. WELL WE'RE NOW
GOING TO FILE ITEM NINE BY
MISTE COOPER THAT'S AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN FILE ITEM NINE. YOU
MAY PERCEIVE IN REDDING. OKAY
GOT IT. SIXTEEN SIXTY OF THE
SIXTEEN SIXTIES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
EXISTING LAW WORK SCHOOL THANK
COLLEGE EMPLOYEE TO CORRECTLY
PENSION ELIGIBLE TO CAL.
UNFORTUNATELY TIMES INCORRECT
INFORMATION TO CAL STIRS THIS IS
LEAD RETIREE BENEFITS BEING
MODIFIED AFTER RETIREMENT
SOMETIMES YEARS LATER SOME CASES
THE RETIREES BEFORE TO PAY BACK
THE OVERPAID ABOUT AND SUFFER A
PERMANENT REDUCTION IN FUTURE
RETIREMENT PAYMENTS. IS EXPECTED
PENSION CUTS GO BACK ON PROMISES
MADE TO RETIREES FOR THEIR LIVES
INTO FINANCIAL TURMOIL A. B
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN SIX TO
PROTECT THESE BILLS PUBLIC
BENEFITS BUST AVERAGING A
PROCESS WHICH ENSURES A RETIRED
TEACHER IS NOT HELD LIABLE FOR
PRIOR OVERPAYMENTS. EXCEPT IN
CASES OF MEMBER AIR. AT ONE
POINT OUT MOST RETIRE TEACHER
WOMEN. OTHR RETIREES NOT VERY
HIGH IN THE LIVE A LONG TIME
MUCH LONGER THAN MIL TEACHERS
MISTRAL BOTTLE. OFFICIALS HAVE
LONG WITH ME TODAY IS SHERRY
JACOB THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ANY RETIRED
TEACHER THANK YOU. AND TOM
CONNERY HE RETIRED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION. A GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHERRY JACOBS AND I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
ALL TEACHERS. ARE RETIRED AND
TO- TWENTY SIXTEEN AFTER
TEACHING SEVERELY HANDICAPPED
STUDENTS FOR OVER THIRTY ONE
YEARS PRIMARILY IN OAKLAND AND
THE EAST BAY. PRIOR TO RETIRING
I FOLLOWED THE DIRECTIONS I WAS
GIVEN BY CAL STIRS I MET WITH
COUNCILLORS I CONFIRM MY
INFORMATION WITH MY DISTRICT I
FACTORED IN SOCIAL SECURITY
OFFSETS. SKYROCKETING INCREASES
IN MEDICARE AND EVEN GAVE MYSELF
A LITTLE CUSHION TO HELP PROVIDE
FOR MY FAMILY. I THEN RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM SISTERS IN JANUARY
INSTEAD OF MY NEXT CHECK. THE
LETTER WAS CONFUSING HEARTLESS
AND MADE NO SENSE AT ALL. AFTER
MUCH DIGGING I FOUND OUT THAT
OAKLAND HAD BEEN AUDITED FOR
YEARS PRIOR TO TWENTY TWENTY AND
I HAD BEEN MISTAKENLY OVERPAID.
I WAS INFORMED MY RETIREMENT
CHECK WOULD BE REDUCED BY A
HUNDRED NINETY SIX DOLLARS AND
THAT I OWED OVER NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO STIRS. NOT ONLY WOULD
I LOSE MY ONLY FINANCIAL CUSHION
BUT I WOULD HAVE TO PAY STIRS
BACK 5% OF MY NOW LOWERED STIRS
CHECK. UNTIL THE MONEY I OWED
WAS PAID OFF. AT THIS POINT THE
REMAINING BALANCE AFTER TWO
YEARS. OVER FIVE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE DOLLARS
. AT NO TIME DID STIRS OR THE
DISTRICT INFORMED ME THAT YEARS
OF PLANNING BASED UPON THE
INFORMATION THEY PROVIDED ME WAS
INCORRECT. THE SITUATIONS NOT
ONLY OUTRAGEOUS BUT DOWNRIGHT
FRAUD. I DID MY PART I SERVE MY
STUDENTS I MET WITH COUNCILLORS
AND MADE LONG TERM PLANS. I
SHOULD NOT BE HELD RESPONSIBLE
FOR PAYING FOR MISTAKES NOT I
NOT ONLY DIDN'T MAKE. BUT COULD
NOT HAVE KNOWN ABOUT. AS IT
STANDS RIGHT NOW THE LEGISLATION
THAT'S OUT THERE. RETIRED
TEACHERS WOULD HAVE TO BE DEAD
NOT THE PAY OFF ANY OVERPAYMENTS
DESTROYERS. AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN WILL GIVE RETIREES LIKE ME
TRUST AND SISTERS AGAIN FIVE
PROTECTING RETIREES FROM PAYING
FOR MISTAKES THE DISTRICTS AND
STIRS MAKE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND ALL TEACHERS I
URGE YOU TO PROTECT RETIRED TWO
YEARS LIKE ME BY SUPPORTING AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A WITNESS ON
THE PHONE FAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
NATIONAL NEA'S WOBBLY MISTER
CONNERY. MY NAME IS TOM COUNTRY
. I RETIRED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT AFTER TEACHING FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS IN THE FOUNTAIN
VALLEY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
FIFTY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I
GOT INTO TEACHING BECAUSE LIKE
MANY OF MY GENERATION I WANTED
TO HELP THE WORLD. YOU CAN SEE
WHAT THE BEST WAY TO DO IT YOU
THAT. WHEN I RETIRED THE SCHOOL
DIFFICULT POPPING A GOLDEN
HANDSHAKE TO ENCOURAGE CAREER
EDUCATORS LIKE NEED TO RETIRE
EARLIER THAN THEY WERE PLANNING
. BOB IT'S MEANT THAT MIGHT
BENEFIT WOULD BE LESS THAN A
FIVE THAT CAN CONTINUE TO TEACH
OF PLANT I THOUGHT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WILL HELP MAKE
UP FOR THAT REDUCE CONTENT.
HOWEVER I DID NOT VOTE ON
MICHAEL MAHAN SICK. FOR A LONG.
YEAR AFTER I RETIRED I RECEIVED
A LETTER FROM CAL THIRD OF
TELLING ME THAT. MY EMPLOYER HAD
MADE A MISTAKE. BY MISTAKE I
WOULD NOT A PART OF. ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING ABOUT. YET I HAD TO FIX
THEIR MISTAKE. THIS LETTER
TELLING ME THAT THE FIFTY
UNIFIED THROUGH DISTRICT DID NOT
REPORT THE CORRECT INFORMATION.
ABOUT MY COMPENSATION AND THAT I
DIDN'T BIG MONEY. I WOULD
PROVIDE YOU ARE. A REDUCE MIGHT
BENEFIT FROM CALPERS UNTIL THE
OVERPAYMENT GREAT. FOR I
COULDN'T BELIEVE TWENTY
CHARACTERS MICHAEL THE CANTIK.
THE CURRENT IS ON AND SIMPLY
WRONG IT SCHOOL DISTRICT REPORT
IN WITHOUT. OF THE TEACHER PAY
FOR. THAT THE COUNTY AFFECTED
REPORT BELONG IN FROM FROM THE
THAT. TEACHER PAY. IT CALPERS
HELP WITH BAD TO MAKE ABOUT HOW
TO RECALL THE CREDIT. THAT HE
PAY. FOR BETTER THE PROBLEM WITH
THE LAW RIGHT NOW THAT WE ARE
TRYING FIX IT IS LONG WE NEED TO
STOP AND GO THE IMMEDIATELY.
WELL THAT LIGHT IT. ARE YOUR THE
PORT EIGHTY THIRTEEN. SEVEN AND
I THINK IT'S MEMBER COOPER STAND
UP. BECAUSE EDUCATORS HAVE LIVED
OVER. ALIVE THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU WITH A YOU VERY IN SORRY FOR
YOUR EX WITH WILL GO TO OTHERS
IN THE ROOM AND SOME YOU MAY
STAY YOUR NAME OF. AND POSITION
ON THE BILL- ONLY MAKE FORWARD.
HI OF. MY NAME IS STEPHANIE BY
MINOR AND I'M RETIRED LANGUAGE
THERAPY FROM THEM AROUND VALLEY
SCHOOL THIS AND I HAVE BEEN SICK
SIGNATURE AFFECTED BY THE
SITUATION I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUSAN DIXON I'M THE
PRESIDENT ELECT AND THAT
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION N. I. TRUNG ALSO
STARLEY SUPPORT AB. SIXTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS
ANGELIQUE KILLING THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN AS
WELL. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAMELA GIBBS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
SOMEWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MARTHA SURIGAO
CITY AS REPRESENTING THE DELTA
KAPPA GAMMA CALIFORNIA AND- THE
ASSOCIATION IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING DROTHY
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. GOOD
MORNING DEREK CLINICS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS PROUD
TO BE A CO SPONSORING THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING SET BRAMBLE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION.
JENNIFER BAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
KNOW WE'LL GO WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONES FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT. TO
THE PHONES. THOUSAND SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR LINED UP OPEN
LINE TWENTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS
GEORGIA MARC BY MARC CAL RGA
FROM DIVISION FIFTY TWO
INVALUABLE OF THAT STUFF AIXTRON
POINT SUPPORT BILL. SIXTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN NINE
THIRTEEN. MY NAME IS CARA
HOUSING FROM- I'M WITH TELL OUR
TA FROM DIVISION SEVENTEEN HERE
IN SANTA MARIA LONG POLK AND I
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT BILL-
EIGHTY SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MIND TWENTY NINE.
HELLO I'M DR KETAN CAL RTA
DIVISION NINETEEN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. LINE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN MIND
FORTY THREE. GOOD MORNING CAL
HYLAND ON THE APP OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FORTY FIVE. LITIJI KIRSTY
ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NINE NINETEEN. GOOD
MORNING. I NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN UP YOUR- ONE EXTEND FROM
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE TO THE
OREGON BORDER FROM THE COAST TO
THE WESTERN HILLS IN CENTRAL
VALLEY. PRESENTING THE RETIRED
TEACHERS AND EVERYONE I SUPPORT.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU
. NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA BALL ON THE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FORTY FOUR. HI GOOD MORNING
YVONNE PATIO ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
APPROPRIATIONS SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MIND FORTY ONE. THANK GOOD
MORNING ELIZABETH ALCOHOL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS AND
WORK IF YOU. MY NUMBER SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIXTEEN. YES
KATHY KELLY WITH A CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE CAJUN CALIFORNIA IN FACT THE
PART OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
MY NUMBER FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FORTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
MANY CHAIR MEMBERS CARLOS ROSS
WITH THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
TWENTY. HI MY NAME IS JUDY DOLAN
I'M WITH KELLER GA FROM ASKING
YOU DON'T CALIFORNIA DIVISION
SIXTY THREE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND THERE ARE
NO FURTHER LINES. THANK YOU ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN THE
ROOM. SEEN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONES ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL ON THE PHONES. ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. NINE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWENTY SIX. ANYONE IN THE PORT
OF THE BELT- BUT I GOT CUT OFF
SO I'M CALLING NOW I'M- I'M
SAYING THAT I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL I'M REPRESENTATIVE STOP
EVEN CALIFORNIA. RETIRED
TEACHERS ABOUT THE BECAUSE
EIGHTY. OUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
. THERE ARE NO FROM A SINGLE
SINGLE TO THE BILL YOU OVER BACK
TO THE I'LL JUST MAKE A COMMENT
QUICKLY MR COOPER THIS IS A GOOD
BILL- FOR VARIETY REASONS NUMBER
ONE IT STOPS THE CLAWBACK WHICH
I EIGHT UNITS. CAN BE. A
DRAMATIC FOR FOLKS TO COME UP
WITH THAT KIND OF MONEY REAL
QUICK RIGHT. AND IT GET OF A
LETTER IN THE MAIL MAYBE EVEN A
CHECK STOP THAT'S A BIG BIG DEAL
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING ON A-
NOT A LOT OF MONEY. AND THEN IT
CREATES DUE PROCESS. AND I THINK
WE REALLY NEED DUE PROCESS IN
THIS ARENA SO THAT- PEOPLE GET A
CHANCE TO MAKE THEIR CASE PEOPLE
GET A CHANCE TO DO THIS IN
PUBLIC. AND LOOK AT THE SPORT
YOU HAVE ON THIS BILL RARELY DO
YOU SEE THESE MANY STARS ALIGNED
SO I COMPLIMENT YOU AND
CERTAINLY YOUR CONSULTANT. ON A
WORKING WITH A VARIETY OF
INTEREST TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN. SO
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT'S A GOOD
BILL OF THE VERY SUPPORT OF IS
THERE ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM
WHICH IS COMMON. SINGLE FOR THE
COMMON IN THE ROOM- I WILL MOVE.
THE BILL. HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- DID YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
THIS FOR FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
AND- AND- I WANNA THINK. MS
JACOBS MISTER CONNERY FOR
CALLING IN AND TESTIFYING
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS. WE'RE ALL
HERE BECAUSE OF EDUCATORS. HELLO
EVERYBODY THIS ROOM. WOULD NOT
BE WITHOUT THIS PLAN LIFE.
WASN'T FOR EDUCATORS I THINK
TEACHERS BUT EDUCATORS IS. A
WORD BUT I'LL- YOU GUYS DID
AMAZING JOB. FOR WHAT YOU DO
IT'S A TOUGH JOB. WE KNOW THAT
HALF THE TEACHERS LEAVE AFTER
FIVE YEARS BECAUSE. IT'S TOUGH I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS DO I
COMMEND YOU. THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. IS ABOUT FORTY DOLLARS A
MONTH. YOU KNOW THE AVERAGE
TEACHER SALARY RETIRED WITH
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. THAT IS INSANE MOST OF
THESE MISTAKES THAT ARE MADE ARE
MADE BY THE DISTRICTS. BOTTOM
LINE WE'VE LOOKED OVER THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY MISTAKES SO THOSE
DISTRICTS NEED DO A BETTER JOB
OF ACCOUNTING THESE FOLS
RETIREMENT BECAUSE IS THAT MS
JACOBS SAID. SHE MADE A PLAN
HERE'S MY TIME HERE'S MY SOCIAL
SECURITY OF THE LIVE WITH THAT I
WILL BE THE CUSHION. THAT
CUSHIONS GOD STILL PAYING BACK
THAT MONEY SHE'S BARELY HALFWAY
THERE. SO IF IT'S NOT RIGHT ON
THE BOTTOM LINE SOMEBODY BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE THAT IS THE
DISTRICTS THAT MAKE THESE
CALCULATIONS BOTTOM LINE PERIOD
OF SHOULD DOUBLE CHECK AND
TRIPLE CHECK IT PLUS YOU
PROTECTED WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
MAKE SURE BECAUSE WE WANT TO
SHARE OUR EDUCATORS. ARE TAKEN
CARE OF FOR DOING SUCH A DUTY.
OF EDUCATING. BUT JUST ARE YOU
FOR EVERY. AND- I SAID I WOULD
NOT BE OUT HERE WITHOUT GOOD
EDUCATE SO. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. GREAT JOB. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER AND IS ONE
OTHER COMMENT. BUT PEOPLE NEED
TO REALIZE TO THIS IS TEACHERS
MONEY THEY PAID INTO THE SYSTEM
THE CHECK WAS REDUCED EVERY
MONTH. ON THE FIRST DAY OF
EMPLOYMENT TO PAY IN. TO THIS
PART OF MONEY TO ASSIST NOT LIKE
A POT OF MONEY THAT'S SITTING
OUT THERE THAT THEY CAN BE
GIVING BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY PUT INTO THROUGHOUT THEIR
CAREER. AND MOST TEACHERS DON'T
GET SOCIAL SECURITY THAT IS TRUE
THE VAST MAJORITY LOOK AT SOCIAL
SECURITY AND INSTEAD CALIFORNIA
THEY WOULDN'T GET ANY UNLESS
THEY HAVE SOME TYPE OF
SIGNIFICANT PREVIOUS. EMPLOYMENT
SO WITH THAT- BUT- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS COOPER. AYE
COOPER AYE VOEPEL CALDERON.
CALDERON I RODRIGUEZ- DONALD HI.
DONALD ICR TO. BILLS ON CALL
THREE VOTE. GREAT YOU WITH THAT
WE GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
TEN IT'S AB NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
MISTER COOPER AGAIN YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
CLEANS UP THE LINES OF VARIOUS
PROVISIONS. IN THE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT LAW THE
EXISTING PRACTICES INCLUDING
CONFORMING THIRTY SEVEN ACT
PRACTICES TO EXISTING CALPERS
AND CALPERS POLICIES FOR ILLNESS
UNDER FMLA. PROVIDE RETIREMENT
BOARDS WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
PREVENT TEMPORARY MANDATORY FOR
LEVELS TRANSACTING MEMBER
BENEFITS. CLARIFIES THAT NON
SALARIED POSITIONS AND PRETENDS
DO NOT COUNT AS DOUBLE DIPPING
FOR MEMBERS APPOINTED A BOARD
POSITION IS CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING LAW. ALLOWS MEMBERS TO
CHANGE THE OPTIONAL ALLEN'S IF
THEY'RE SUBSEQUENTLY GRANTED
DISABILITY RETIREMENT. I AM
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
COVERED DILIGENTLY WITH THIS
SEIU CPF PORAC IT TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
RESULTING IN A FAIR COMPROMISE.
WITH TODAY'S DATE NIELSEN
SECTORS LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CO
CHAIR AND CEO OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT. GOOD
MORNING- SHARED MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE ON DAVID HERE TO REP
SACHER'S STATEWIDE. OF COUNTY
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK- CHAIR COOPER FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL WHICH HAS
BEEN ENDORSED BY THE SACHER'S
BOARD UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY
THE ATTACKERS MEMBERSHIP AND
THOROUGHLY VETTED WITH.
STAKEHOLDERS CHOI COOPER IS VERY
ABLY OUTLINED THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL SO I WON'T REPEAT THAT
INFORMATION I'LL JUST SEARCH
YOUR SUPPORT MIGHT BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
ANY FOR ANY OTHERS AND SUPPORTED
YOU HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. OF THE PLAN THIS IS
WHAT YOU DO NOT GO WITH THAT
WILL GO TO WITNESSES ANY PERSONS
IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. SINGMAN ANYWAY ON THE
PHONE TO A TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TO THE PHONES. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
. AND THERE ARE NO LINES ON THE
PHONE NO SUPPORT ON THE PHONE-
ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
SINGLE OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM TO
GO TO OPPOSITION ON THE PHONES
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINE NO OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE
HAVE MOTION ALL SECOND YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER COOPER RESPECT ME
AFTER I VOTE. WITH THAT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MISSION IS TO
PASS COOPER HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL
CALDERON CALDERON I RODRIGUEZ.
O'DONNELL HI WELL DONE ICR TO.
THE HAS THREE VOTES. THANK YOU
THAT BILL IS OUT. WAS SUCH AS
KEEP CALLED UP THE MEMBERS- NO
ACTUALLY CONCLUDE OUR HEARING- I
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR- TEN
MAY. ONE OF THE OTHER ITEMS TOO
SO. IT'S JUST A CORRECTION
MISTER TO THAT LAST BILL IS ON
CALL THANK YOU. SO MOTION FOR
CONSENT. OKAY MA'AM SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
PREPARATIONS WITH RECOMMENDATION
TO CONSENT CALENDAR COOPER AYE
COOPER AYE VOEPEL CALDERON
CALDERON HI RODRIGUEZ O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I. TO BILLS ON CALL
THREE VOTES. I AM NUMBER TWO AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE WE NEED A
MOTION. SO WE'LL- AFFECT. THAT
BILL IS DUE PASSING BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER AYE COOPER
VOEPEL CALDERON. CALLING ON NOT
VOTING. RODRIGUEZ HOTEL
RODRIGUEZ I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
I SEYARTO THAT BILL IS ON CALL
THREE BOTH. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
IN NINETEEN TWENTY ONE THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS THREE VOTES
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I THE BILL
HAS FOUR VOTES ON CALL. THE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY THREE WE NEED A MOTION SO
MOVED. THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
COOPER HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL
CALDERON CALDERON I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
I SEYARTO HAD BILL HAS FOR VOTE
ON CALL. I AM NUMBER SIX AB TWO
FIVE TWO FOUR WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE VOTES RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ
I WE HAVE FOUR VOTES THAT BILL
IS ON CALL. THE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX
WE NEED A MOTION SO MOVED. THAT
MOTION IS DEPRESSING BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COOPER HI COOPER I
VOEPEL. CALDERON CALDERON I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I SEYARTO AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SIX ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. HI C. R. TWO I. THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES WILL PUT IT ON
CALL. THE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWO EIGHT SIX ZERO WE NEED A
MOTION. THANK THE MOTION AS YOU
PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER COOPER I VOEPEL. CALDERON
CALDERON I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I SEYARTO
SEYARTO NO THE BILL HAS A FOUR
TO ONE WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
. ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THAT CURRENT THE
VOTE IS CURRENTLY ON THREE TO
ZERO VOEPEL RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ
I SEYARTO SEYARTO I. MR VOEPEL
WE ARE CURRENTLY ON ITEM NUMBER
NINETY BE SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE VOTES VOTE
HELLO VOEPEL I THAT BILL IS OUT
SIX TO ZERO. ITEM NUMBER TEN. AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE THAT BILL
HAS THREE VOTES VOEPEL. VOEPEL
NOT VOTING RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SEYARTO C. R. TURNOUT VOTING
THAT BILL HAS FOR OF VOTES IT
IS. OUT. GO BACK THE ROLE IN.
MORE TIME. OKAY I AM NUMBER ONE
CONSENT ITEMS FOR TWENTY FIFTEEN
WE HAVE THREE VOTES VOEPEL AYE
VOEPEL I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SEYARTO THEY ARE TOO HIGH THE
BILL HAS EXPLODED OUT. I NUMBER
TWO AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE VOTES
VOEPEL. AYE VOEPEL AYE SEYARTO.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE
PATTERSON. SEYARTO I THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS FIVE VOTES IT IS
OUT. THE ITEM NUMBER FOR AB
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES VOEPEL
. VOEPEL I SEYARTO THEATER I
CAN'T BILL WITHOUT WITH SIXTY
ZERO. I AM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY THREE THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES VOEPEL. HI VOEPEL I SEYARTO SAY ARE
TIGHT THAT BILLS OUT SIXTY ZERO
. I AM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR THAT BILL CURRENTLY
HAS FOUR VOTES VOEPEL. TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR CAR COVER.
KNOWS VOEPEL KNOWS THEY ARE TELL
SEYARTO NOTE THAT BILLS OUT. FOR
TWO TO. I KNOW NUMBER SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS FIVE VOTES VOEPEL.
HI VOEPEL I THOUGHT BILLS AT SIX
TWO ZERO. I KNOW NUMBER EIGHT
ABLE TWENTY SIXTY THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR TO ONE VOEPEL
. NO VOEPEL NOW THAT BILL IS AT
FORTY TWO. IT OKAY CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING THANK YOU.